well it's such a such a great great
[Music]
she's there everywhere um yeah I see
you've been familiarizing yourself with
our our obedience disk it's a little
invention of mine by the way
you know some people find it kind of a
neurotic walk with me I'm gonna tell you
something obedience disk I've never been
crazy about that name I was supposed to
be a placeholder until I can think of
something better but everybody started
to call them obedience is what I didn't
hear anything but weren't those like
sparkles out of your fingers like
lightning may be really located your
cousin oh good yeah there he is hey cuz
we almost couldn't couldn't find you
already been hiding hmm so I got to
admit what you did
Carlo what you said it was only a small
camels why did you do this small camels
gambling gambling I don't know what that
means gambling with the Canela camping
you just said it was camping there's no
survive
Camping's bad but what you really do I
was gambling gatlings
Oh gambling is no good hmm Carlo I
pardon you
they do it again though right
officially officially pardoned from life
[Applause]
let's stop there you know what I woke up
this morning thinking about a public
execution I did I really did but for now
I'll settle for this sweet little who's
gonna get first so while you're on the
clock
this means go did you not get that
that's the universal sign it was I not
clear heaven's sakes what did you make
of that there's so many universal
symbols this is one that's obviously not
communicable what's this dial it down
that's dial it down what's this get out
no smaller okay here I'd like dessert
here's I'd like dessert mmm that would
be as if to say this would be
I won't do this anymore
hey the boat not pay the bill this would
be that would be pay the bill this is
where's my cheque where's my cheque
please my cheek
[Music]
so my last housemate left all of a
sudden but fortunately through my work a
position came up in Los Angeles so I
needed to find a new housemate hello the
grand master was the only one who
answered my Craigslist ad yeah imagine
that I was the only one well lucky me
at first I thought he was just another
Hollywood type person then I realized he
was more than likely from another planet
I like learning about your culture what
do you call this toast yes I come from
Sekar it's a haven for lost things that
sounds kind of poetic but it's really
kind of a catch-all place and now
without boring you with the details I
had formerly infrared or a long period
of time a an assistant slash bodyguard
named topaz and now you know I'm looking
for a new assistant and you know who
seems to fit the bill just perfectly
believe it about is Darrell
[Music]
Sekar is ruled by the Grandmaster played
by Jeff Goblin and he's insane and
colorful and hilarious I pardon you from
life
the Grandmaster is the photo negative of
Odin he's in very high status figure he
does things with disco grandmaster
improvises I'm practicing now this full
section which includes me as Grandmaster
playing with a band we wanted that
character to be really memorable and
Goldblum is just perfect I'm going back
to Asgard a scart I can't stand him all
that familiar he turned up Taiwan and
blue solo I asked place ass Berg eyes
God I'll tell you this and this is
honest it was as good a time as I've
ever had cabbie jab jab yeah it was
really fun exciting and I liked what we
were doing
you